they're called patent trolls companies  have acquired the rights to a patent but  don't actually sell or produce anything  they've built patent arsenals often  collected from the abandoned stockpiles  of universities failed startups and  defunct big tech companies once they  build their war chests those trolls go  out for blood  targeting companies whose technologies  are similar to those outlined in the  patents they threaten costly lawsuits  unless licensing fees are paid out so  most troll attacks are settled out of  court through non-disclosure agreements  in fact of the 4,700 patent lawsuits  filed in 2012 3,000 were from these  so-called patent trolls